ينضم إلي الآن لمناقشة كل هذا
أنا جيمس إلدر وهو المتحدث الرسمي باسم
اليونيسف وأشكرك على وجودك معنا
لذلك نحاول الحصول على تحديث حول
الوضع وأريد أن أسألك لقد
كانت أيامًا قليلة صعبة للغاية أه
خاصة أننا نقول للأطفال أه، لقد تعرضوا
للكثير من الغارات الجوية كانوا تحت
تعتيم الاتصالات، ما الذي
تتعلمه أكثر عن
الوضع جيدًا بالضبط هذا القطب الذي في
الوقت الحالي، خلال ثلاثة أسابيع فقط،
كان لديك أطفال مليون طفل،
فلنكن مستعدين للغاية  فقط ضخامة
عدد الأولاد والبنات الذين رأيت
القليل منهم هناك أكثر من مليون طفل
يعيشون في الجحيم ولكن ما نراه
بشراسة وقسوة هذه
الهجمات من القصف حين
تسمع التقارير الصادرة من
وزارة الصحة في غزة، بينما
لديك مليون طفل
يعيشون في الجحيم، هناك عدة آلاف
يموتون هناك، لذا فمن المستحيل
الآن المبالغة في تقدير مدى خطورة ما
يعانون منه، فأنت
لا تعرف الماء ولا الأدوية  لا وقف إطلاق نار يا
باولا، نحن نتجه نحو هذا النوع
من
الرعب الذي لا يمكن تصوره، والشيء الصعب
هو أن هناك طريقة للخروج، وهذا
واضح جدًا وقد قلنا هذا
منذ البداية وهو في
الواقع ليس معقدًا مثل الباقي
قد يرى العالم أنه وقف لإطلاق النار
وأنه يهدف إلى فتح تلك البوابات والحصول على قدر
هائل من المساعدات للفتيان والفتيات
وإلا فإننا نتلقى تقارير عن
مقتل أو إصابة مئات المئات من الفتيان والفتيات كل يوم
وعندما نتحدث  حول ما
قد يكون عليه هذا التعطيل، أعني أنني ذكرت أن لدينا
الرئيس بايدن ماكرون يزن الآن
أيضًا العديد من قادة العالم المختلفين الذين
يقولون إننا بحاجة إلى المزيد من المساعدات، ما هو
التعطيل، وهل
تشارك اليونيسف في محاولة
كشف ما هو التعطيل؟  لقد حدث هناك عند ذلك
المعبر، نعم، إنه سؤال رائع،
أعني أن هذا يعود إلى السياسة الآن.
تستخدم اليونيسف كل نقطة وصول
وكل شارع وكل قائد سواء كان
الشركاء الأكثر محلية على الأرض في
غزة، أو الأشخاص الأشجع الذين يحاولون
الحفاظ على كرامتهم  عائلة آمنة والحصول على بعض
الأجزاء الصغيرة من المساعدات التي لا تزال
موجودة للناس أو كما تقول،
سيستخدم مسؤولو قادة العالم اليونيسف
كل طريق يمكننا استخدامه ولكننا نرى
القليل من الدماء ونرى أنك
تعرف اثنين من  عشرات الشاحنات تدخل
الآن، لدى اليونيسف 14 شاحنة بها
مياه وأدوية ستنقذ
الأطفال، ونحن نعلم أنه إذا حصلنا على
200 شاحنة أخرى، فسنحدث
فرقًا في حياة هؤلاء
الأطفال حتى لو سمحنا بعمليات القصف
التي لا نرى أي معنى لها
إنها نفس الرسالة من
الأمين العام من
مديري التنفيذي لليونيسيف، نحن بحاجة إلى
زيادة هائلة في المساعدات، إنها أساسية جدًا، كما تعلم أن
لديك الآن حوالي 5٪ تقريبًا
من نظام المياه يعمل، لذا
بينما نرى هذه  صور رسومية
تصويرية للأولاد والبنات الذين تعرفهم والذين
تم انتشالهم من تحت الأنقاض،
أمهات يعانين من قدر هائل من الحزن والذين
سيستيقظون في حزن كل يوم لأنهم
سيستيقظون دون أن
يصبح ماء أطفالهم الصغار أو بناتهم
تهديدًا حقيقيًا للأطفال.  كذلك لدي
زميلة في غزة، ولا يزال لدينا
العديد من الزملاء الشجعان وقد تحدثت
عن طفلتها البالغة من العمر أربع سنوات فقط قائلة يا
أمي، أريد فقط مياهًا عادية، لأن
المياه ليست قذرة وغير آمنة، فهي
ستحصل على طفلها الآخر الذي يبلغ من العمر
سبع سنوات.  تحدثت عجوز عن الصدمة
التي تعرضت لها وأنها الآن
تعلم أنها تتحدث عن ابنتها وهي
تخدش نفسها لدرجة نزيف فخذيها
وعندما تتحدث مع
الزميل حول ما يمكنك فعله حيال
هذا المستوى من الصدمة التي تواجه
كل طفل  في غزة، قالت ببساطة إن كل ما
أركز عليه كل يوم هو إبقاء هذين
الاثنين على قيد الحياة إذا كان بإمكاني إبقائهما على قيد الحياة، وأنا
أقول لنفسي كل يوم، عندها سأنظر إلى
الصدمة
التي ليست سيناريو عاديًا وغير مقبول لأي
شخص.  الوالد بول بالطبع كما نعلم جميعًا
وهو أيضًا سيناريو يمكن تجنبه وأعتقد أن
هذا هو الأمر المفجع للغاية
الآن من حيث كونه
سيناريو يمكن تجنبه على الرغم من أنني أعني أن
إسرائيل تواصل إخبار الناس حتى
في المستشفيات الذين يحتمون
هناك  العائلات التي يجب عليهم
إجلاؤها إلى جنوب قطاع غزة،
ما مدى قلقكم في الساعات
أو الأيام القادمة أم أن الأشخاص الذين يحتاجون
إلى الاستجابة لهذا النداء ربما
لن يتمكنوا من العيش بشكل
جيد، أعني مرعوبين؟  أشعر
بالرعب لأن الجميع يشعرون بالرعب في كل لحظة من
هذه الأسابيع الثلاثة الثلاثة الأخيرة سواء أكان الأمر كما
تعلمون، أعتقد أنه
أطفال إسرائيليون في العشرينات من عمرهم موجودون في
مكان ما في غزة ويحتاجون إلى الخروج
على الفور ويحتاجون إلى إطلاق سراحهم وإعادتهم
إلى عائلاتهم أو كما تقول في
المستشفيات، من غير المنطقي الاعتقاد
بأن شخصًا ما في وحدة العناية المركزة بالفعل عندما
يكون لديك عدد أكبر بكثير من الأشخاص الذين هم في أمس
الحاجة إلى المساعدة الطبية والأسرة أو طفل
في حاضنة وينفد
الوقود لدينا ويمكن نقل جميع الأدوية
في مكان ما، هذا ليس هو
الحال ببساطة، زملائنا من
منظمة الصحة العالمية قالوا منذ أسابيع إن هذا حكم
بالإعدام، لذا فإن هذه
التحذيرات ببساطة ليست واقعية،
ومرة ​​أخرى عندما نناقش ذلك، فإن ما
يعنيه ذلك هو أنك إذا كنت أمًا
ورأيت الشظايا تتذكر بولي لقد
رأيت ما تفعله الشظايا بالطفل، فهي
مصممة لتمزيق الأسمنت
والمباني، فهي مدمرة
لجسم الطفل إذا نجا طفلك من ذلك،
والآن أنت تصلي من أجل أن
ينجوا في المستقبل  أيام ويقال لك أنه
يجب عليهم الإخلاء ويقول الطبيب
حسنًا، أنت تعلم أنه يجب علي الآن اختيار
أي من هؤلاء الأطفال في وحدة العناية المركزة سيعيش
أو
يموت، وهذا غير مقبول بموجب أي
قراءة للقانون الإنساني الدولي،
ولهذا السبب ستستمر يونيس في
استخدام  في كل طريق يمكننا فعله، سواء كان ذلك هو
الخير الذي تعرفه، أو الضباط الجيدون
من أعلى القادة في البلاد،
سواء كان المذيعون مثلك
يطلبون تلك الأشياء الأساسية،
زيادة هائلة في المساعدات المقدمة
للأطفال ووقف
إطلاق النار، سيتعين على جيمس إلدر أن يفعل ذلك  اترك
الأمر هناك في الوقت الحالي حيث نواصل الأمل في
وصول المزيد من المساعدات الإنسانية إلى أه
غزة وخاصةً لهؤلاء الأطفال، شكرًا
لك